cette affaire qu'il y avait eu moins de
retentissement que la mort de georges
floyd mais elle a une portée tout autant
politique c'était le 23 février 2020 un
jeune afro-américain de 25 ans avaient
été tués dans l'état de géorgie une
affaire rendue publique suite à la
diffusion d'une vidéo qui a alimenté la
colère bien sûr des militantes du
mouvement black live matters et le
procès s'est ouvert ce lundi écoutez les
précisions de notre correspondant thomas
bonnin c'est un procès très long et
particulièrement inflammable qui s'est
ouvert ce lundi à brunswick dans l'état
de géorgie le tribunal va devoir juger
trois hommes accusés de la mort de la
mode arbres y un jeune afro-américain de
25 ans tué en février 2020 alors qu'il
faisait un footing
les trois hommes sont un père qui est un
ancien officier de police son fils donc
et leurs voisins qui a filmé la scène le
23 février 2020 il avait pris en chasse
amo darbary à bord d'un pick up puis le
plus jeune des trois à laver a battu
pour leur défense les accusés ont
expliqué avoir tenté d'arrêter celui
qu'ils estimaient être l'auteur d'un
cambriolage mais le procureur affirme
pour sa part que rien ne relie hameau
darbary à un cambriolage il rappelle que
le jeune homme n'était pas armé au
moment des faits à l'époque il avait
fallu attendre plusieurs mois avant que
les accusés ne soient finalement arrêté
puisque ce n'est qu'au moment de la
diffusion de la vidéo de la scène que
les autorités ont ouvert une enquête et
puis la faire a trouvé un écho
médiatique très important dans le cadre
du mouvement black live matters le
président joe biden a même twitté au
mois de février dernier à l'occasion du
premier anniversaire de la mort de ce
jeune afro-américain
depuis l'état de géorgie a pris des
mesures législatives en abolissant d'une
part le droit aux citoyens de procéder à
des interpellations et puis d'autre part
pour réprimer plus durement les crimes
racistes quant au procès qui s'est
ouvert ce lundi il s'annonce hautement
symbolique la sélection des 12 jurés
pourrait prendre beaucoup de temps parle
de semaine parce que les autorités
judiciaires veulent s'assurer de
l'impartialité à des jurés qui vont
constituer ce jury populaire il pourrait
y avoir jusqu'à mille personnes 1000
citoyens américains qui pourraient être
auditionnés justement pour constituer ce
jury et puis il faut noter enfin que les
trois accusés seront également jugés en
février prochain par un tribunal fédéral
cette fois où un procureur les a
inculpés de crimes racistes